又大漲了今天大漲500多點
轉眼睛
46000了
前陣子在3萬9折折你們每根爆酸財產
對啦
我一下子賺到快1500萬收化者
重點是
你能不能賺錢
我今天最開心的就是我的細節還能夠展霆的
這也不是重點我今天跟你講三個重點
第一個台股重版46000 5萬將7000達標嗎
哇從本一定很多人想知道5萬會不會達標
是每個人都想知道事情對不對
會不會8月95萬點
第二個我1.050 1.050 11天而已
11天左右賺得快1.5萬
1億賺1.5萬
扯折很坦的賺
我希望你能了解到
我坐這邊
我待在這邊
就是為大家服務
這些錢我並沒有在乎
到時候我還要捐一台救護車
第三台救護車
公開廠已經都捐了好幾千萬了
第三個
何時出這比較重要
MSCI新增很多記憶體的股票
有一個就是我們的群年嘛
還有一個是我之前的不見了練人了
已經把他先分一陣子
藍牙科三進三出
會不會四進四出
會不會五進五出
這些標股先通通一次講得夠
台股天天大漲距離台股大跌
到今天才兩周多的時間
就從最低39,384.1路噴到突破46,000
11天的時間台股就漲了快7000點
真的太強啦
而投資長的標股今天又是狂噴猛噴
國巨今天噴漲停啦
只有投資長在跌停百456.5元
當天告訴大家這邊就是要買
這幾天一路噴出由低到高
已經大漲超過45%
還有投資長一直說太委屈的環球金
也連兩天漲停啦
中美金也差點就張聽
另外今天早上 MSCI 新增了南亞科群聯和華邦電
想知道投資長是怎麼看的嗎?
投資長的會員們都已經要財富翻倍了
你手上還沒有標股嗎?
接下來就交給我們經濟日報選股冠軍
單計 188% 的紀錄保持者
同時也是全台灣唯一百萬粉絲最受歡迎的分析師
郭哲榮投資長
投資者好
Lily 各位能不能 大家好
又長500點
如果11年前
有個分析師跟妳講 雜一億
那你要雜多少錢
你們那53%投票表覺得
我們投票不是投
投票的 還有53%我賺掉錢
希望他們覺得投這個票覺得有點丟臉
怎麼會還有錢
叫你把租公租債通通債拿來用
就有錢嘛
我不知道你現在是開心大於難過還是難過大於開心
很矛盾的感覺對不對
果不要漲上去了
今天也有人問我我的國劇1200怎麼解套
奇怪國劇1200怎麼解套
你買一張500塊的國劇那你現在就1700
是不是你800多元就可以解套了
是
你房地要不買
這怎麼沒錢了
不要騙自己你有錢
不要騙自己我知道你還有錢
不要解這段
真的啦
39000你自己看
哪個分析在39000改革你就立馬
你告訴我就39000
而且我是前一天就預告要跌破39000
前一天預告要跌破4萬
4萬來到39000我就買
買1050
所有的新聞那天至少
八家報紙雜誌
不只關電視台就八家
對不對 沒錯吧
因為立家是在旁邊
8家 猜翻我
一家接著一家來
一家一直接著一家說對不起
我是給你10分鐘的時間
因為我太忙了
新聞媒體爆沾雜誌可能幾十家
全部人都知道買1050
隔天你還可以買購相同的位置
你不理我
幸福來得又幾又快
11天的時間 2 4 6 8 10
10天而已喔
我給你一天的時間
後來10天談了多少
快7000點
390,000多到現在4萬6千多
投資票
我跟你講當我的粉絲就好出
因為你看我第一次
這只是買1億
這炫耀
你要有粉絲
第一個很多人說
你要能湊出這1億
第二個你要敢買這個1億
公開買
你要買了1億
要馬上一天的時間
就馬上賺了一千多萬
那我再跟你講更誇張的事
你們全部的作證沒有我現在一舉工
更誇張的是你們自己看
我請問大家一件事情
哪一個分析是在連續三年都在低檔的時候
之前跌六千點嗎?沒錯吧?沒錯
我在那時候是去年這時候才一萬七
你看股市長多兇
去年四月的時候關稅議題
我說川普馬上怎麼樣
馬上就會取消這個關稅
而且會透過它的什麼
它那個應該是真實
他這個一個社群媒體
他自己獨特社群媒體
會透過他的社群媒體
果然凌晨好像11 12點的時候
他說關稅要延後
馬上股市噴出去
而且我還預告說
會展
就算股市大漲1000點
就算股市產品要追
有沒有印象
有嘛對不對
有
有印象
來
如果我刻意說的話,非常誇大,我現在來取空
大家都可以坐鎮,我覺得在這附近
18,418點的附近,近長,台灣50
連續兩年,後來長了3萬點
連續三年的時候,2024年更漂亮
等於可以右長,又可以右出的長可以黑半
在這邊我盡量能空手空手,跌了4千多點
在這邊馬上反彈
所以這邊很多人說,怎麼會打跌這小,我說,你要幹嘛
奇怪每天想這些萬一幹什麼
哪個分析師可以連續三年在股災的時候都選了一個相對最低點
三年都是相對最低點
2020年也是最低點這一天了
今年也是一樣
一次叫一次運氣好
兩次叫碰巧
三次叫神機
奇蹟
我的奇蹟一再出現
所有網友們你自己見證
有沒有講有
好不好
有好不好
今天國際會暫停直接專案的
國際是說嘛
你看我真的不要說我講話
我說我做得很公道
不要說什麼搖持機抹肌膜他啦
我說沒有啦
他們也很辛苦經濟能壓力很大
我們都感受到
因為很多人覺得只是在吸效怒
他們不知道其實我壓力很大
只是我去享受的壓力
我告訴我自己
我是真心未味很好
我真心未味粉絲好
沒什麼好什麼壓不壓力的
我就度過這一切
你們懂我意思
所以我做自己而已
可是我做自己事情,我希望是我把我帶給大家,帶給大家,你知道嗎?
來,愛者則有沒有?
有,大家都說有,有,莊美金金還是有產變,擔心換錢機會拉起來
OK,0981A都30,而且我是不是說過,我說如果是我,如果是我
如果今天是折折我
我可能要買ETF我會先買0.98A
我真的講
然後我再換台灣50
因為反彈0.98A會彈比較快
0.98A彈快30%
我如果不單分一是我是少賺1500萬
你不要看我現在賺1500萬我是可以賺3000萬
只是我說如果我不單分一是我也不買0.98A
我就直接買國際就好啦
是不是我們講對於買華人星就好啦
有啊
再賺更多啊
所以你不要羨慕我賺1500萬
我是因為你們不讓我少賺
我也可以買這二
只是我是工作人物
工作人物我在這
我就是什麼
我其他生我不管
因為我不知道我們哪一天
我都不小心闖完燈
可是重點是我投資的道德標準
我很高
我投資的道德標準很高
這我對自己的要求
沒有
所以我不會去私底下去買股票
不需要我少賺一點就好
我讓你知道什麼叫答案
我當分析師你看我賺1000元,我其實少賺幾千萬
我每次都這樣跟你講,投資率我不能做期貨
賺更多,每次低檔都進場
誰敢這樣子,跑頭落裂
那是你們看我,哇,嘩,嘩,嘩,嘩,嘩,嘩
一天就轉上去
你告訴我誰那麼厲害
我早就跟大家講我天分在這邊,你知道嗎
年底只得幾家成為傳說
沒有錯,我換點
可是我跟你講,你們都是一群詐女
現在給人力回不到
直播人數回不到一兩萬
你知道嗎 之前的點閱率
二二三十萬 三十萬
現在沒辦法
No no no
你們真的讓我很三心 你知道
哪一天大跌
我就把我頻道縱起來
OK嗎
啊
就給那些時鐘粉絲
我是認真講的
給會員看
給會員看 或給粉絲看
你們還只會按讚多一點 你知道嗎
你看 四千多人
你看這189個按讚 我氣死多了
說嘴巴說愛我
真的愛我嗎?來 今天就有人說 哲哲
我真的為什麼這麼多人愛哲哲?你知道嗎?
還有人問 哲哲是誰?
為什麼這麼多人愛他?你知道嗎?
是不是?我回答很簡單
不好意思 引誘人家的 引誘這個美女的
應該是美女
是美女 妳這樣講美女嗎?對不起
哲哲是誰?為什麼這麼多人愛他?
因為很多人在認識我之前不知道什麼是愛啊
整個是誰為什麼都愛他
因為很多人在認識我之前不知道什麼是愛
認識我以後才知道什麼是愛
什麼是大愛
什麼是骨片的愛
什麼是希望你過得比我好
的愛
我那時候有沒有說
再給整個一次愛整個機會
再給自己一次愛整個機會
有
不然你會後我一輩子有沒有講
我捨身起義
啥幾叫人
一 丟下去
壓力多大
那是現在對的
性存者偏差
就知道厲害
如果不對 怎麼辦
可是神奇是我連續對三年
都在最低點附近
好 兩年就是剛好最低點那一天
另外是隔天
隔一兩天都很強
來,我們講一講,這個優化都越來越準
你再看一下我的東西
我看今天很多梗應該到那邊會截圖
當你覺得3萬9的台股是可格可氣的時候
有沒有對吧?
是
3萬9沒什麼,你自己看
但怎麼樣?你是可格可氣的時候,我再買進來
當你覺得3萬9的台股是可格可氣
可以割除、可以丟棄的時候
不好意思,我看你是4萬3的時候
我覺得你很可惜
現在4萬6了 我覺得可憐
等到4萬6、4萬7 現在是可憐的
5萬的時候是可悲
可惜可憐可悲
不好意思 你們現在已經感覺到很可憐了
有些人現在空手的人最可憐
我就說過我昨天不是 不要再測試一次吧
我昨天不是說 AI
我就要用中國新東客服 中國新東客服
他也可以當副班經控的客服
那我副班經控的客服我是不是說過很簡單
我說過那這個AI就很重要了
為什麼 你看這個訂單本來是14個月前對不對
我這個你推廣 我再講一次
推廣託論
推廣託論這一塊會爆炸
我這個你第二個預告
你看華爾街都沒有給你預告
我很屌 我跟你講
我認為推廣託論這一塊的爆發程度
會比AI agent
就是你們說的龍蝦
我這個預告喔
沒有分析師可以講這句話喔
華爾街也沒有喔
拖管推論這一塊會比龍蝦
就是AI agent 就是
你是AI 我幫你代理我的email
我的信箱
AI代理程式是發展更恐怖
Anthorpig就靠這個嘛
我跟你講接下來要賺這個
拖管推論managed inference
這個很簡單就是我請
比如說我請這個這家公司
Cole Whiff
這家公司的回答的兒子
我請他怎麼樣
比如說我這樣講 AI
我知道現在一般的AI已經能夠對話
所以我請他幫我推論出來
幫我升一個一般的AI程式
專門否我們副班經考
或我們中國經考
我們是模仿的 不好意思
專門否副班經考
或中國信託
這一個
然後最好還能串接
我會講話的同時
我會查出你的額度來
是不是線上可以幫你直接申請成功的
這有可能的
越少能力越好
我賺越多
越少能力我關
是客服人員一年
台灣就要省500億
你們想過
按理相看做推管推論這家公司
現在不多
等到你知道的時候已經如雨後存行般了
所以有人說哲謝謝哲
你讓我知道這個生意頭腦
他說可以做,我說以後你參與業飲也可以,不需要接電話
你可不可以找客服幫你接電話,接完電話就直接串接
或直接幫你訂單直接處理人,以後不止Uber一直訂,你也可以用電話訂
幫你做客服,串接你的,串接你的LINE承受,串接什麼承受
那我這些電信業者或是電信業者的客服,通常電信客服也是每次都打不進去
你也可以串聯名字進去
我請Kowif做拖管推論
我告訴他我的需求 你伸出一個AI程式
AI語音程式或AI程式
讓我們公司的作業流程 讓我們公司的客服
我要航空業也是 航運業一樣
我們都常常打電話
這些抱怨的電話 我可以用AI處理 我不要人能處理
客製化
什麼叫客製化 代表每一家公司都有這個需求
所以這個市場多大
你們看不出來而已
數字機體的多少 我算一下這個多少
一般的分析是這樣子 華爾街分析一般也這樣子
台灣分析是也不怪他們的
真的喔 我不好意思 我講話比較屌
你們不知道這個市場 我跟你說
每一家公司都需要AI 你告訴我
這個AI是很樓大
如果有人給我推賣我城市說
不好意思喔 我們可以省兩個能力
那你做兩個能力
一個能力我們平均薪水都
現在都今年薪水不錯 大概80到100萬
兩個能力省200萬
200萬是永久的 我們可以做別的事情
不一定要敗人家
200萬他說你一年我只賣你100萬
買買買啊
那100萬他看頭啊
這個人賣100萬 那個賣100萬
那他投資個幾千萬去買這個
去跟人家買這個拖管推論
OK 生出在城市好不好
這講也是拖管推論這一塊
以後會變主流
比AI Aging還快 還更是主流
今年靠展的從26000到44000是AI權
可是AI權你知道什麼問題嗎?
AI權是你幫我做事
他沒有一個三頁體系
為什麼?
你幫我做事情
對啦,你幫我比價
然後呢
你會因為你幫我比價
去買這程式嗎?
No, no, no,不一定喔
你懂嗎?
可有可無嘛
我給我打最便宜的價格
Triple打看最便宜的機票怎麼樣
最有購買力道的是公司,公司行號,你告訴他不好意思,我幫你省了500億的人力
我現在只要跟你收1年10億,你要不要?OK啊,OK啊
他要跟銀行收這個錢,或者他要跟一般參與業,我一般各個公司給你收這個錢
第一要先透過 我不可能 哇 找那麼多程式來寫
或設計師或買GPU或買AS服務器
你有AS服務器 你幫我跑程式
我什麼需求 你幫我跑 跑出來這個程式
這個語音課服或這個程式 利用脫鉤推論這一塊
GPU晶片 你都提供 程式你幫我想幫我生
懂不懂 答案出來 這需求多大
沒有分析師可以講這一塊
No 他們在記憶體怎麼樣 關是這一塊你就知道
我這也是每一家公司都需要AI
以後都這樣
因為它可以改進它很多城市
所以這個跟2000年差太多了
那些講那些人根本就不知道什麼是AI
記住一句話
三年前卻GBT一出來的時候
全台灣只有我郭忠負經理想
這接下來改變了一類的命運
只有我講AI股市會佔一整年
有印象舉手
後來我就說改成三年 到現在第三年
我再跟你講 現在開始
不只還會再好三年
你們趕快把錢湊齊 真的還會再好三年
所以這些記憶體被動元件暫停了 暫停了 正常
那交給最一般的分析師解釋
哎呀 我們那個EPS多少
哎呀 我們這個毛利率多少
只要看數字說話 我是預言家 不一樣
我不一樣 你久就知道 看著的一次少一次
你越是了解股市的險惡 越是了解股市的人
越知道我跟別人不一樣
只有那種不懂股市的人去講
只能講得很正常
我是跟你說真的
貝道元賤我整講2018流收三過
我有賺大錢又收三過
所以你看這次我吃他豆腐幾次
三進三出
今年是兩進兩出
兩接
第二進還沒出
還沒出
你可以不可以買華興科和珍藏新商店
他們都是聯動的
所以有人國際權貸買華興科
現在謝謝我愛上我了,愛上我智慧是很棒
是不是?
全台灣只有折折敢提前喊破事外要買意義
而且會提前喊沒錯
好不好?OK嗎?
ETF基因人都在看折折分析股市
蠻多人看我節目的
國際態扯了,好不好?
你用準則能分析高利嗎?
高利不是我補票,好不好?
今天怎麼感覺一群的習板
來 相信哲哲國際環境新賺寶 謝謝大家
不要在他洗板 不要同一個畫面 不要是洗板
重複一個畫面 超過三次就要先封鎖你了
來 我只俊不確
愛哲哲是自食不餘的愛 千萬別在那說
我最怕這種 有些愛情都說一輩子愛的時候
那時候不一定很長 好不好
你們先愛我今年就好 好不好
先今年就好 先今年啦
我嘴巴這樣講是兼今年啦 好不好
OK嗎
幫大家科普花時間研究,我不只科普花時間研究,我直接預告未來
那些科普網路上的資訊不會告訴你說,沒有一個新聞,沒有一個現在報答告訴你
我說脫管推論這一塊,就是你幫我們公司整個作業流程
然後改進,會是以後會是趨勢
你今天不是台灣大哥大買金層資訊嗎?
溢價30%吧,為什麼一堆工程師在那邊?
現在顯示很簡單,但工程師比較了解這些程式的架構
以後也是這樣,深入各個公司
OK嗎?
這跟大家講
夜盤四萬六沒站穩,你們每天在緊張中緊張
為什麼拿阿科華班念平盤?
因為中石物主力比較淺
夜界蠻有名的,今天6000人看直播太早
紅海為什麼跌到?
紅海就昨天沒有劉漢偉出來啦
起死 我本來劉漢偉出來
昨天是代理的那個CEO
講的不溫不和啦 好不好
我覺得就是很普通
他有講說很好啦
但那很好沒有比大家好
天龍在做什麼嗎?
在你現在要知道
土火管推論
你有看到我是全世界第一個這項獎
我沒有人敢講會比AIH的市場更大
因為每一家公司
或者說我要多售給這些公司
我要多售給金控公司
我都是一般的業者 零售業者
然後我怎麼生出來一個語音客服
或是我怎麼改進人的作業流程
這個以後很恐怖
你懂不懂
以前會覺得改進作業流程很麻煩
現在其實都可以做得到
都可以做得到
你聽懂嗎
好 來
那我們來看一下
來 所以我們今天推出逆轉188專案
好不好
最近剛好股票比較強
所以推個專案
要不參加隨便你,你轉188,剛好者則是獲利188%男人
全台灣都知道經濟日報有史以來最高的懸鼓記錄保持者
所以我打破很多記錄,怎麼會有人覺得者則是運氣好的
運氣好的,你敢在,你敢買一億,你敢公開給人家笑
我買一億就準備不要給人家笑的啦,懂不懂
準備我笑那些空手,我希望你不是真的空手
我希望你就算還有錢,只是一點點有錢
我不希望藉由誤怒你來成就我不需要
我希望是你跟我一起提升
好不好 我是認真跟你講
我剛講可憐可惜可悲
那只是節目的語言煽動力而已
那你記得而已
可是我沒有 我不需要批評你
我不需要見他其他人來增加我自己的執行
不需要 我希望是你跟我一起轉錢
可是我要告訴你們一件事
為什麼我買最保守台灣物品
我隨便買個0098A
買個路不當分音師
買個0981買個正二
甚至買期貨或者買被動元件
隨便都賺個多賺個兩三千萬
隨便都賺個兩千萬
為什麼我沒想做
因為我是分析師
因為我寧願當分析師
把愛給大家
我少賺一點沒關係
但只要你們有愛
有愛我真的覺得整個是為你們好
那就夠了
你知道嗎 整個之間順風順水
有些人同意網路上
愛一定要夾過以前的東西
哪個分析師沒有賠過錢
哪個人是沒有賺過錢
可是我只要賺的時候比賠的時候多很多就好了
人在做天宅看我沒差
大不了我自己操作我也沒差
可是我告訴大家
我40種我就覺得
我希望你們比我好
我40種人在那裡
好不好 你轉移到巴抓你自己參考 好不好
來來來 股票要暫停的
來看一下國際暫停的對不對
對
是不是 我昨天有沒有說過 寄生魚和生釀
寄生周...那個...
周子魚 不是不是周魚
周子瑜
最近好像聽說什麼TWICE什麼
周子瑜要離開了
我不知道
我不知道什麼跳出這個東西來
脆
寄生粥
寄生粥魚
和生粥
粗葛亮
寄生魚和生量
寄生具
和生糖
我們說和生糖怎麼樣
你看今天和生糖就沒起來了
我說和生糖昨天都快700元了
國劇怎麼可以
怎麼可以差那麼多
但是他們今天兩個就拉近了,國劇今天是展平版
合資上就下去了
還是有展平差不多
所以寄生聚合生談
兩個就是這樣
博眾之間
你們講都講
都講再講
這個邏輯很簡單
一個族群如果是一起發動
通常是真的
如果一個族群就依然染股票發動
那個不一定會動
一個族群一起發動代表是不是
就是他們這個被動員去這個行業
有些人可能某一家中石戶
大戶是跟這家公司派合作
領導有可能
那另外一個大戶B大戶又是跟
可能跟第二家非洲元氣人員公司合作
或者他知道這個消息
所以他們會一起動
因為他們都知道未來發展
這是有可能的
兩個分析是跟你們講的東西
我們不一定講什麼仔細
那計時分析
如果重慶難弩現在沒什麼書局了
一般書局成品書局買到的書
計時分析就能來賺百萬 賺一億
你相信喔 那裴觀光剛好
一定要技術分析在籌碼面 在心裡面
你告訴我 哪一個技術分析告訴你
4萬點這邊是買進
破線欸 破機線欸
這講一件事 現在大家純粹是分析
或怎麼樣 我覺得AIS Palmer
根本就不知道我講哪一段
如果你剛才聽懂我這一段
你還覺得AIS Palmer
我只能說你傻的可以
我也是 如果我剛才今天講AI克服語音
我講的是其中AI某一個東西而已
他AI他已經聰明到智力
已經比我們所有人都強了
這是事實
你知道嗎
我們要與一些公司更公司要改合約
是
他可以講出來你邏輯上的問題
一堆問題
很恐怖 一般的律師
這就像下象棋一樣你知道嗎
下象棋或是下圍棋
他已經贏不了人類
人類已經贏不了他
因為人類罵像電腦想的那麼絲
周考、思考這麼整密
因為你法律是這樣子
邏輯戰很強
他的邏輯戰的思考程度
已經比一般人整密10倍以上了
沒錯
所以你就要去改法條、改條款
你交給他真的很恐怖
我可以利用他做很多東西
法律客服也可以
太多東西人同志嘛
真的喔 這我跟大家講
好不好
人心機器也有機會
立即練有機會嗎
我們稍微看一下
所以你在問法有點討厭
那幾天 現行不錯
好不好
只是環懂走了
相信環懂 聯敵就懂
環懂走了是覺得滿可惜你知道嗎
可是我會覺得人生就是這樣子
燃燒最後一刻 你那時候還要罰說
我也希望我只能燃燒最後一刻
只是我到越老可能錄影時間越少
好不好 是跟大家講
因為我覺得集中活力
你不覺得我現在錄影時間越來越少
還是錄得比一般老師多一些
可是我的績效又會轉
你們覺得有齁
是不是 真的啦
就不像這麼真的 你們問大家就好
所以我覺得利基電我們現在沒那麼喜歡
是失去了一個
一個支柱嗎
做一個支柱 真的 好不好
這更大 也是奇葩啦
是不是 公司
雖然戰鬥毛幫他很多忙
但你從利基電能預火重生
他也是個負責任的人
他大隔拍拍屁股頭人
是不是
把債務 有股份有限公司嘛
把債務丟給銀行
他也不這樣做啦
關這一點我就覺得
我覺得人人就是這樣子
重承諾 重責任
就是應該這樣子
我說我欣賞他
好不好 我欣賞他 是可惜
還成 還從人走了
這是為什麼有時候特別結一下股票
就是還算欣賞他 好不好
那個
英雄洗英雄 不要這樣講自己
哲哲洗英雄 這樣好不好
只是跟大家 所以立即定我沒有那麼看好原因
不要說沒有看好
就是說少了一個還從人
我不知道對家公司是好還是壞
就這樣子而已 好不好
我們可以選比較穩的嘛,就像我剛才講,你比較穩
前幾天,你現在前幾天每個人在罵我,環球金、環球金
奇怪,環球金兩根展平板你都不理我
喔,你知道嗎,那時候我賺一億馬上賺一千萬
就說,這支煉的環球金好爛喔
這支煉的環球金抵到七百多元了,你真敢講
他有人故意同業,他故意同業在網路上留言
你七百多元你敢講你賺一千萬喔
我說我很生氣啦
講這什麼話
我寧願我不賺那一千萬
你們更不了解我 我這也是
認識我都知道
我寧願我不賺那一千萬
我台灣五十賠錢
我也不要會員賠錢
我說真的啦
如果我真的我說真的好不好
就說我不會去刻意做這個事情
你知道嗎 是
是不是
沒有
我沒有開心
可是我說
人家講的就沒有開心
可是我很開心
778元是老天爺送給的禮物
我錄下一天在嘴唇
我那時候我說
台積電600元是老天爺送給禮物
跌到500元 跌到400元一對人嚇我
現在呢
我說你再也見不到600元台積電 你見得到嗎
見得到嗎 你告訴我
見不到
你現在是不是再也見不到1000元的環球經驗
我不知道
黃岸千豪的膜 但2000元有機會
我自從跟你講 我告訴你
各行各業有關AI到時候都會缺貨
都會經過一輪缺貨
我在講一件事 這個拖管推論
我們就是 我請你幫我寫個AI程式
服我們公司的
以後
會越來越多人的用
為什麼會越來越多人的用
我再講一次
以前 怎麼下面底下的留言
應該要跟我聊這些
現在就有一些 AI 客服了
那個 AI 客服爛得要死好不好
跟我昨天講的差不多 我講的沒錯吧
你以前有預告 AI 客服好像白痴一樣
那個你會講話會生氣
那是為了省成 人力成本的省成
可是現在 AI 客服是真的你可以把它對話起來
那一段時間後 它把你的需求記起來
比如說我要檢卡怎麼樣
要我們的雲端系統
是
銀行的內部系統
然後把你檢卡
把你做一次做完
以前是要人類幫你按手動
那不用
我再去找
他都聽懂我的互動
他不會再寫個程式
我站你的互動以後
我站你要檢卡
我自動電腦就幫你檢卡
可是這個要一個程式產生
以前程式產生不了
因為以前AI像自戰一樣
現在AI真的AI
就是因為現在AI像聰明的天才一樣
所以我們可以開始寫一些程式
寫這些程式
問題是我GPU
我要推論 要導論
你知道嗎
我GPU去外面買 買不到
所以我找人幫我買
我找人幫我寫這一層詩
而這些每一家公司都有需求
因為我只要省了一層本 我賺很多
每一家公司都可以省
所以以後屏幕差距會越來越大
你們不會玩投資股票會差距越來越大
很多人會覺得被剝削
是真的
是真的 我想知道的話
可是很幸福
但你們選擇的時候 你們看到未來
真的 這是我存在最大意義
真的啦 你就還從人到最後
為什麼最後一刻還開那個什麼法社會
他有差那個幾千萬嗎
你們真的你們也不要看紙紙這樣子
我說真的好不好 我說真的
我覺得有時候得到我的運氣很好
老天至少沒給我太傻的腦袋
可是我覺得有時候
我也是取之以色 我要用之以色
所以我該捐錢 該捐錢
有時候我最開心捐錢
我也買很多好的車子
但我就 我還是會買
但我覺得最充實的是買救護車
真的是這樣子
買個500萬救護車不錯
很開心雖然救護車越來越貴了
以前3、400
可是我很開心
明年應該
照這順序應該有沒有可能年初就6萬
我會捐第三台救護車
這進度很快
我有說過22台
22個縣市
折折資源居買
資源要爆發時間比較難抓
資源存在是低檔而已
算了10萬
資源存在是低檔
你聽懂嗎?等他一下,OK嗎?
那鴻海再不拉搶,我也打算要撤退
撤退是要成本負傾
這則鴻海怎麼看?就是我昨天講的昨天
代理CEO,假萬不夠87,OK嗎?
這跟大家講,只能等劉良偉什麼時候要講
比較好的話
這則寶貝群年噴噴,謝謝你
剛才很多人說要跟我姓
要姓郭,OK郭氏家族,大家好
群年噴噴怎麼看過去?
相信則則稱奇
所以我就是你的神奇寶貝
沒有 人笑
青年噴噴噴怎麼看東西
青年是一樣
這個MSCI 你看我還是有作圖
MSCI概念果來看一下
新增六檔噴到
三升
三升 三個市場升起來
三升三四
沒有
新增萊亞科華班念群年們的
有沒有人固有差?
群年就是便宜嘛
群年便宜啦
我們講說就奇怪
你們都不理我
很多人都覺得那是同業的
固怎麼念我?那念我很少
1445你不覺得是老天爺送給你
你看現在反昂也差很多
2280除145
記下
也快68了
快68了
你們想過?
真的耶
真的差很多
快60%了 57%
是
57%
轉眼間
群年你真的相信我有57%
所以這一次的股災
根本就老天爺送給你誤
從到回股災我是前世
你要了解我看到的未來
每一家公司以後都需要
有人幫你生成一個AI程式
幫你們簡化你們公司的能力
作業流程
或者是對外的客服語音
或怎麼樣 whatever
這是無眼無覺,以前為什麼沒有人做到
因為以前的AI程式,以前AI克服像死一樣
現在是真的比大家聰明,這是事實,AI也比我聰明
我比較厲害的是,可是AI不會取代我
AI會取代那些死都不用AI的人
不論你智商多高,你不用AI就準備被淘汰
你記我這句話,你再強調我這句話
你不知道AI多恐怖,那你準備被淘汰
我跟你講AI很恐怖,你還去用了以後你還覺得不怎麼樣
很危險 你就這句話
你認同我講的話 我有職業生涯危機了
我這個行業怎麼樣 汽車 駕駛行業
我這個行業怎麼樣 那你還有的舊 你要的幫助你
你第一個 你要嘛就換工作 要嘛就買AI股票
我是認真幫助你 相信我 你會謝謝我
真的 我是與說我賺錢 我不覺得 我就幫助大家
讓大家有認知感 你知道嗎 有時候認知感
我突然失業了 好難過
可是我講了好幾年了
我人家接受這事情
你就不會激動
你就不會難過了
你就覺得我反而有賺到錢了
你反而很開心好不好
我是真的希望頒出大家
一定要用AI
各行各業都用AI
超過你想像的智商
如果你不覺得那你很危險
記得我這句話
你說一定要說我會比人家成功就是
我一定要說你會比人家成功
我不去預設特別立場
我是看到哪邊
證據在哪邊我就辦到哪邊
證據在哪邊我就說到哪邊
ok嗎
Nag哥劃半電群年
Nag哥的中時務很猛
沒有關係
我們這波也不錯
是不是
我剛才說57%對不對
今年514
530處於322好了
沒關係
他64%
所以我剛好開始覺得群年沒有漲很多
對不對
其實現在快要追上Nag哥的漲幅
是
一個57%一個64%
沒關係 也不錯
是不是
二指責怎麼看
劃半電好像沒有漲的比群年多
對不對
沒有怎麼看 華班店如果殺下去我想買
因為我覺得我買一檔 因為說實話我只買一檔記憶體
我覺得太少了 聽得懂嗎
就如同我有點後悔我只買一檔國具太少
聽得懂嗎 還是有點後悔 我那時候
但我下去我已經買很多股票
有興味 我趕快買環球金 買中美金
所以華班店或者是說
那個華亞科
不得話可說 那個292 光環機
華星科
這交加那個交師的這個集團的華星集團的股票
就是被動元件的 一個是記憶體的 一個是被動元件的
這些 我有想買你知道 老二族群的股票
我會想買你知道嗎
我已經買很多老大的了 那個每個老二也不錯
因為大家還是 因為我一直有新會員你知道嗎
你看我也沒有要推銷這個疫苗專案
可是就很多人來問
今天有人留言說
我按那個要參加會員的媒體
沒人理我
不好意思 你現在按你要參加會員
還真的可能沒有人理你
等一下
太多人了
沒關係 你現在直接留言說你是哪一位
不然你再丟一下訊息給我
按TG來丟一下訊息給我
好不好 這跟大家講
不過誰沒有理你呢 我再跟我講一下
這不行打個入會專線
入會比較快
這沒有入會專線應該會
我們會聽語音
我看一下誰偷懶
不是偷懶我們公司的人很忙
那個金圓店、年電館達可以嗎
館達都變大了
館達看金圓法說
是要看一下金圓法說
加碼年電人生、大電買個老二
全部老二概念果
機體買老二,買華班店,然後貝多元店買華新科
然後先進日程不買台積電,買年電,老二族群
不要啦,其實老二有時候差很多
我之前就買年年店,少賺很多
又帥又頭腦的折折,請問金圓店的群狀
這不是我股票,金圓店我以前變成罵
好像都出掉了
金圓店現行還好啦,看起來不太會噴
你看這個陣子這麼多都沒有動
之前就沒有爆發的題材
展上去以後頂多啦
這看線型就知道不用看
之前就在區間整體平台有沒有到
從上看基督線型大家可以學到
雖然這張股票不一定是你的股票紀念店
就算噴出去的
還是會在這個區間平台
懂嗎
瞭解
目前為止是老狗玩不出新把戲
目前
OK 講你的股票就好
不講,我不提你,我講我的股票,中美金怎麼軟掉,我們看一下
其實我跟你講,中美金不用擔心,為什麼不用擔心?
環球金沒有陣亡,中美金就沒有理由陣亡
環球金沒有陣亡,中美金就不會死,甚至還會補漲
現在股票談不到20%的投票
187.5%對不對
最低是150%
現在是187.5% 最低是150.5%
這一段到目前今天
24%
現在股票還有沒展三成
20萬訊,所以他會有補產的題材,知道嗎?OK嗎?OK
來,管達第二季的經歷高達287.9億元,私下監民做AI圖,怎麼可以?沒關係
那優於市場共是243億元
管達第二季的EPS是7.43元嘛
2382管達 管達第二季月是7點
4.3
有沒有意外收益 有沒有意外
玩友看到的話 幫我回答
因為我現在在這邊 我們要把查除掉 幫我查很快
私下各位看一下 7.43有沒有含意外
沒有含意外的話 明天管達會噴出去
我們要7.43對不對
算一下 7.43 假設乘以4
對不對 這麼簡單
一年大概賺30元嘛沒錯吧
是
我去年入福利社的時候
我去九州七年管討機會30元
大家都不相信我印象中
是啊
那你看29.7元了是不是
阿向古叫做
本一倍都11倍而已
11倍不到
10倍本一比
我真的想要撕紙
可以撕
頭長上是說要提醒不可以撕
非常撕
還要到市值還要到市值沒有
7.43元
第一季PS台5.5,第二季7.43元
要求7.3元
325除以大
我已經想買管達了
除以大,看29.2
命向
沒有
沒關係
除以大,看7.多少
除以7.43,在除以4一樣的意思
你們數學不知道沒關係,我直接告訴你們答案
10.9倍的本益比
我們聽錯,台股快5萬點了
10.9倍本益比,這要是個股票是加一戶小
不懂我怎麼買得到,明天先噴再說
OK,管達我重新考慮要不要買回它
好不好 折冷靜
折說要噴一定會噴
明天應該有機會噴
OK 來 氣調獅子 完全已經最香了
所以台股怎麼會貴
台股好貴 台股本來比很貴
你看哪些股票 台大店很貴
管台股也不貴嗎
今天來個股災 記得跌個2萬點管
也不會死多慘
你看像我們都專業的
你看你們隨便烤一個東西
我都臨時那你們考
你看什麼AI語音課服都臨時這樣子
你知道嗎
都臨時都在Live跳舞也是Live的這樣
搞得像明星一樣
壓力很大
跟你們隨便問我
問不倒我
問跳舞可能問倒我
問在頭腦
我關股票投資相關的
我就是贏家
看一下這些什麼
一下賺200%
新星以前賺100%
你有沒有看到
年初有沒有看到新星300多
你不要開玩笑
現在有新星球800塊就不開心了
有沒有看到
我都買在低點
是不是 聯發科國巨也是一樣
這是賣掉的機效 管達327
327我賣掉 現在是327
那我明天考慮再買
好不好 OK嗎 再買一次他
不錯吧
我考慮 謝謝大家
我也是很正面思考 你應該要問我管達
我覺得有點股票不錯
我考慮明天買 我真的買
那會買
你不會參加會員
你不能每天問我啊各位
是不是 便宜的
免錢的最貴 記得這件事
我從頭到大我就不會被騙
我剛剛路邊的 幫你塗一下 幫你怎樣
不要
有人要免費對我好 我還不要 我是真的
有人要免費對我好
你知道很容易被人家詐騙 都覺得穩的
很輕鬆可以賺錢
免費的
其實會被騙的人 我不是在工錢家
都是覺得免費的不一定不好
這也是 會被騙的人
錯了 免費的最貴
我突然不相信這種事情
所以我覺得我們會費合理 你知道嗎
要不要參加隨便你
我不知道跟你推銷
我知道怕你被騙
這要怎麼搞 跟大家講
所以你不要用
可是你不參加會員沒關係
可是你不要叫我免費服務
沒有這回事 不好意思
要免費服務很簡單
你就等一年一次
台灣50什麼時候買鏡 好不好
你就跟著做就好
國巨三個展覽版來來練一下
8月13號星期四早上9點22分
恭喜2327國巨開高走高一路機拉
成功鎖上掌聽
我們買進到現在最高已經大賺快31%
我持續看好他手上持股活力續報
恭喜大家賺大錢拉
國巨大家都跟上了嗎
國巨大家跟上了沒
所以恭喜2327的國際開高投高一路走一拉
成功收到暫停吧
賺31%
這是普通會員簡訊
暫停暫停暫停啊
你要買的時候已經買不到
你看我為什麼你已經敢追暫停
勇者啊
環球金也是一樣弄到
今天暫停的
要暫停的
你們這堆人擠著抱怨
那折折怎麼是訓折的
怎麼只有你賺
你不懂嗎
那時候跌的時候是讓你賺更多
你隨便買環球金賺的比我台灣50多
我現在賺1500萬元又怎麼樣
你買個環球金都賺的比我多了
大家
是不是
恭喜六四八號環球金股價開高走高一路急拉
成功所佔涼平
我最高一大賺80%
你有沒有想過一件事情
我一檔股票我記得好像賺得170%
左右
這是環球金
天啊我都沒走
為什麼1600我沒走
打算2000以上,3000以上啊各位
我再講一次,你要懂我什麼脫管、推論這一塊
每一家公司到之後都需要AI
以前不需要AI是因為以前AI像自占一樣
大家知道發現AI可以取代很多人力的時候
每一家公司都願意花錢找一個人生出來AI
城市找一家公司
所以這些AI公司就可以變現
就會賺錢 就不會泡沫了
講AI會泡沫是傻瓜
他根本沒在用AI
你們沒在用AI 不要講AI是泡沫
沒有資格 既有講這句話
所以這些有所有的股票 基本上還會再創新高
很幸福 我要幸福 因為你要記得一件事情
趕快存錢起來 這個以後再說
為什麼 你以前 我看了像日本人很像很可憐
我20幾年前我還記得
哇 我家人的姐姐的朋友
哇 爸爸500萬日圓那時候我覺得很高
那時候500萬日圓 台灣200萬
那時候可能台積電員工可能不到50萬
沒關係 可以開玩笑
薪水不到50萬 現在呢
他們現在500萬都偷笑了
可是500萬不到100萬年薪
對啊 因為才0.190.21
500萬日圓 台積電已經變300萬了
十年賀東十年賀新
以前就是日本的世界
現在是台灣的世界
趕快趁這時候把錢存起來
賺大一筆
我不知道以後十年我怎麼看
我不知道後面十年怎麼看
可是我知道這五年來台灣會賺翻天
好好把握
不是一輩子這樣吃香蚵辣
我就是很準
我也不一定一輩子吃香蚵辣
可能要趁我在吃香蚵辣的時候
參加我會
我看很遠
你有和10萬點是胡扯喊的
我最佳問題面子不是那一千萬的
5萬點 說到就會到
10萬點 我老實跟你講
那是因為我公開講
我不覺得五年才會達到
我也不覺得四年
有可能三年以內就達到
我們可以看一下
這麼快嗎
10萬點 有可能三年內就達到
有沒有想到你
有啊
10萬點有可能三年內達到
從現在開始三年內
只是我不想
這句話我不想要變主打曲
主打哥你知道嗎
因為我要保守一點 我怕我萬一
三年內就有機會失敗了
笑到你了
三年了 我不是亂講話
你記得為什麼我穿到這麼多季度
不論是我的
你告訴我你為什麼特別電視節目
我們以前從電視頻道出來的
問那個財經頻道捧國者
好像沒有
根本就沒有 為什麼還這麼好
為什麼? 蠢啊 不然咧
真的你以為這隻帥 當然很多人有些人覺得我帥
我不賺錢會帥嗎?我不能賺錢帥嗎?
就是你想想我的未來好不好?預測未來 記錄這句話
10萬點很快就來了 記錄這句話
AI每家公司都需要AI
每家公司到社會都會買AI的應用程式
一度 恭喜548萬多美金 股價表現成是
一度噴到快暫停 手上吃不飽飽了
紅海已經比較弱 管達明天可能拉起來
有沒有可能管達拉起來一起拉紅海?
也有可能 我怎麼去買管達?
不過加碼鴻海 真秘密啊 好不好
真秘密 自己要不要參加這個專案
自己考慮好不好
這我不勉強 逆轉 188專案
自己來電下去 080 680 85 好不好
來 我們最後再看一個股票
所以你看 中美金拉回 不要擔心
管達不錯 管達最新的財報不錯
對 挪威的主權基金都來台灣了
這個沒時間講 你看我做那麼多 AI 圖
真的很認真 你看
鴻海的訂單人見度
挪威主權基金都來台灣了
所以很多外資是氣寒果
氣寒寶台
所以你要保護主線
現在幾分了
50要結束了
我們看到什麼股票
53 47世界先進
是不是
世界先進也不錯
世界先進缺點是沒有跌很凶的
都有機會噴出去
哎呀
就中美金很甜
到時候就跟六四八八環球金一樣
是不是
700元你再瞞著抱怨我
結果現在已經1000元了
是不是
不要亂抱怨者
覺得群點一樣
一堆人那時候在抱怨
你們到 這樣談成這樣怎麼到
國劇你也在抱怨是不是
是不是我幫了很多人忙了 搖直擊母什麼的
希望我能幫到他們
希望他們有覺得我幫到他們
沒關係 沒關係
至少國劇就是第一檔
是我給你的信心
OK嗎
記得你去看看你要怎樣分營資
賺的1500萬 什麼時候要走
至少5萬點以上 我打賺還是6萬點才走
賺的大概5000萬 6萬點以上才走
MXCI新增多長記憶體要噴的
記憶體本來就會噴的 什麼都會缺
5萬位提早達標
8月5萬我沒有信心
我也不喜歡戲一下演完
可是今年8月5萬點是沒問題的
我認為是沒問題的
不論對外作者 者一切一切
預告前面 去想看你要怎麼回事
我們好多股票很強
還忘記講這些什麼微星啊
什麼今天創新高啊
真的沒時間講的好不好
精彩的機會就創新高
這沒時間講一堆股票準備在創新高
你去想想看你要折返平時好不好
今天太多股票暫停了啦
真的啦
64.8環球已經國劇你告訴我誰最懂被動員界
It's me
要不要跳舞
你要跳 開玩笑
會跳嗎
不會
不會 那算了
改天學一下 沒有來開玩笑
好啦 就這樣子啦
去想想看你要折返平時想清楚想明白
歡迎來一下行怎麼樣
08068085
逆轉1188專案
來一下行或者怎樣
直接私信我小二組
S178 不論對我做什麼一切一切
又要前面 哇
一億的台灣50 馬上就賺了1千500萬了
可是更多是更強的國票
環球GNA連續兩天展平版
國劇好多天展平版
你想看你要展開的原因是
遠欲注各位賺大錢
先從逆轉18號專案開始
謝謝各位 拜拜
本節目資料僅供參考
投資人應獨立判斷
整身皮肤並自付投資風險